sometimes a movie is destined for the
dollar bin and even Hollywood's biggest
stars directors and producers can't
polish into something worth paying to
see these cinematic flops just didn't
leave the impact Studios hopes they
would so say it with us bombs away
there was a time when the name Robert
zamakis was up there with the likes of
George Lucas and Steven Spielberg the
director of such Classics as Back to the
Future Forrest Gump and Castaway then
fell in love with the possibilities of
computer-generated imagery or CGI his
fascination with the technology art form
made sense so macchias was an early
adopter of similar Innovations on Who
Framed Roger Rabbit but aside from
2004's of Polar Express which made big
bugs for the box office but to this day
remains Infamous for its creepy lifeless
animation his big budget CGI takes on
Beowulf and the Christmas carol debuted
and disappeared quickly from theaters
in 2011 the maccas produced Mars Needs
Moms with Protege Simon Wells writing
and directing but when it came to The
Uncanny Valley Factor the off-putting
effect was the same this late in the CGI
game there was really no excuse for the
motion capture animation in Mars Needs
Moms to look so ugly and unsettling
James Cameron's Avatar and wild
audiences two years earlier and other
breakthroughs had taken the medium a
long way since Polar Express ticket
buyers didn't connect with the title the
story or the central characters in a
post-mortem studio Executives concluded
that boys weren't interested in a movie
about mothers and younger children may
have been scared off by the premise Mars
Needs moments became one of the biggest
box office bombs of its time making less
than 40 million dollars worldwide
resulting in a loss of more than 100
million dollars
the Android Lloyd Webber musical counts
with a record-breaking hit on Broadway
we're running from 1982 until 2000. it's
a massive success was something of a
surprise a practically narrative last
show based on the Poetry of T.S Eliot
that is really just a sequence of songs
and dances about a list of fictional
cats with names like Mustafa Jones and
Jenny any darts but because cats made so
much money in one format Executives at
Universal were willing to bet that it
could do it again never mind that
musical adaptations have been struggling
in the decades since Chicago had ranked
in 10 times as budget and won best
picture and never mind that cats were
sought to be among the trickiest
Broadway smashes to adapt some Hooper
The Man Behind the 2012 film version of
Les Miserables signed on to direct and a
star-studded cast was a symbol that
featured everyone from Jason Derulo and
Taylor Swift to Idris Elba Judy Dench
and Ian McKellen fans of the musical
sensation wondered how realistic the
cat's movie would be as the stage show
simply isn't then about five months
before the film was set to Premiere a
trailer gave those fans their first
glimpse of the titular animals and many
were horrified by what they saw these
cats for cavity I'll Deuteronomy Mr Miss
tar Feliz were disturbing human feline
CGI live-action hybrids it was too late
to change course audiences hoped for a
movie that might be so bad it could rise
the level of Camp pleasure unfortunately
the pandemic derailed any possibility of
Rowdy ironic screenings and cats never
recouped its cost
Jack London's trim but powerful 1903
novel The Call of the Wild is required
reading at middle schools All Over
America an anthropomorphic allegory
about a hulking mixed breed dog who must
evolve from beloved pet into fearsome
pack leader in order to survive it has
been adapted for the screen multiple
times but isn't exactly the type of
story that lends itself to
straightforward cinematic retelling but
one thing there isn't much of an
overarching linear narrative to the
journey of the dark named Buck for
another it's told entirely from the
perspective of the big mirt while other
characters humans and canines simply
pass through despite the fact that it's
so regularly assigned to Children The
Call of the Wild is also inceasingly
brutal it's basically 200 pages of dogs
ripping each other apart not the best
choice of what 20th Century Fox intended
to be a big budget family-friendly
Christmas release the original densely
literary novel aims to claw away at the
facades of civilization and capitalism
revealing the Grim nilistic truth
underneath instead viewers got this you
must sleep two days
in my bed
from the trailer fans of London's could
tell they were getting a sanitized
version while the general public wasn't
exactly begging for yet another remake
of a 120 year old book Harrison's Ford
was in between reprising his roles in
Star Wars and Indiana Jones and was very
much back in the Zeitgeist but the real
stumbling block was Buck a far too
artificial looking and expensive CGI
creation that undermines the entire
effort in the end the studio took a
roughly 50 million ice bath on the Call
of the Wild one could argue that Robert
Downey Jr was the biggest movie star in
the world at the end of 2019. he was the
centerpiece of Avengers end game the
extraordinarily profitable Capstone to
the first three phases of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe audiences loved him
three thousand and couldn't wait to see
what he would do with his post MCU
career no one expected it to be this GG
bro
I brow as well when you've got a second
right sorry first up for Downey was
2020's Doolittle ostensibly a family
film based on the second of author Hugh
loftings Dr Doolittle works the fact
that do little had been delayed until
January a time when Studios typically
dump what are predicted to be losers was
worrying still downy's presence and a
Stella voice casts which included Emma
Thompson Tom Holland felima Gomez and
Ray fines just to name a few gave
Universal and audiences reason to Hope
but the trailer seemed to confirm
everyone's worst fears viewers couldn't
help but notice that Downey's accent was
to put it mildly a bit odd if the best
jokes were in the trailer they caught
wind of the fact that the film's sense
of humor might fall flat the expensive
CGI heavy visuals also didn't do much to
inspire a sense of wonder in prospective
audiences ensure to do the tool look to
be a disappointment once critics and
families got to see the final product
word got sales about just how bad
Downey's supposedly Welsh affectation
was and the film ultimately came to be
known for an important extended fart
joke Duluth tour made 251 million
dollars but it was so pricey to produce
a market that it still ended up costing
Universal money
not two years after cats crashed and
burned Universal tried again with the
Contemporary Broadway musical dear Evan
Hansen the play about a high school
student struggling with mental illness
had gained a loyal following thanks in
part to catchy music penned by Benji
pasik and Justin Paul of the greatest
showman Fame rather than wait two
decades Universal got to adopting dear
Evan Hansen so immediately the same
actor who'd originated the role in New
York was set to reprise it for the
forthcoming film but once the trailer
aired even those loyal fans began to
doubt that the 27 year old Ben Platt was
the right choice to portray's 17 year
old Evan it wasn't just some plotted age
for years it was how he was styled and
how differently the character came off
in those intimate close-ups which had
seemed emotionally honest on a stage
suddenly seemed cringy when translated
to the screen there was also the matter
of what dear Evan Hansen was about
Broadway shows only have a single
theater's worth of seats to fill but the
movie had to sell tickets at more than 3
000 Cinemas across the country but Buzz
out of the Toronto Film Festival where
it premiered didn't do it any favors the
curtains closed early on the film
adaptation of dear Evan Hansen which
made a poultry 17 million dollars
worldwide in its three weeks of wide
release back in 1995 the artists and
storytellers of Pixar dreamed up a
simple but satisfying premise for a
children's movie what if toys came to
life we weren't looking that premise
spawned four well-received films one of
which Toy Story 3 was even nominated for
best picture at the Academy Awards the
franchises dynamic duo Woody and Buzz
became icons then Disney announced the
fifth film focus on the latter that
complicated the original premise so
thoroughly and unnecessarily the fans
literally didn't understand what the
studio was trying to do it was a real
drag good luck Captain
[Music]
adding to the confusion was the fact
that Chris Evans as opposed to Tim Allen
will be voicing the character this
change alone angered some who speculated
that Allen had been passed over because
of his political beliefs spoiler alert
he wasn't Evans tried to do damage troll
tweeting just to be clear this isn't
Buzz Lightyear the toy this is the
origin story of the human Buzz Lightyear
that the toy is based on but that turned
out not to be true either 2022's light
year wasn't about a toy astronaut that
doesn't realize he's a toy astronaut nor
was it about to fix no but supposedly
real astronaut from Andy's world even
after trailers dropped and announcements
were made a Disney investor day in
cinema Khan prospective audiences were
still scratching their heads it took a
title card cut to the beginning of the
film to finally clear things up it read
in 1995 Andy got a toy that toy was
based on a movie this is that movie but
by then audience says had already lost
interest in light year
not so long ago an R-rated romantic
comedy especially one produced by Judd
Apatow could do well enough at the box
office to justify its existence by and
large that time has passed it's been an
eternity since a comedy let alone a
rom-com has landed in the top 10 highest
grossing films of the year the last one
to do so was 2011's a hangover Part 2
and the last true rom-coms to break that
ceiling was 2005's wedding crashes and
hit suffice it to say the odds were
stacked against Bros from the start but
they were stacked even higher because it
was the first major studio rom-com and
centered around a gay couple after Bros
fizzled house co-writer and star Billy
Eichner infamously took to Twitter to
express his displeasure blaming
homophobia for his film's poor
performance while there could be true to
his theory given the current political
climate it likely underwhelmed for
reasons in addition to its subject
matter well Eichner has fans from his
Funny or Die show Billy on the Street
and from his time on Parks and
Recreation he's not as familiar to a
broader audience Norris's co-star and
love interest McFarlane best known for
appearing in Hallmark movies also there
wasn't any urgency to see it on the big
screen as Bros was available to stream
within days of its release
nothing lasts forever
[Music]
even fans of the dceu will admit it has
never found the same level of
consistency as a Marvel Cinematic
Universe 2019 Shazam was a bright spot
it got better than decent reviews and
made better than decent money and
compared to the often Tower films about
Superman and Batman was Charming in a
way that some of the best MCU movies had
been of course it was going to be a
sequel as was the case with a majority
of films that went into production in
2020 the pandemic caused stops and
starts nevertheless fans remained
optimistic since Stars Zachary Levi and
director David F Sandberg were both
returning then Warner Brothers announced
that they had hired James guernan Peter
saffron to reboot its DC Comics Universe
which meant Shazam Fury of the Gods no
longer felt like it had a place in the
universe's overall continuity another
Striker gains the Shazam sequel Black
Adam the Dwayne Johnson vehicle should
have tied into the Shazam storyline
since the characters are so closely
connected in the comics instead Johnson
interfered in a way that hurt both films
and Warner Brothers ended up with not
one but two box office bombs on their
hands Shazam Fury of the Gods never
captured the previous film's magic last
The Originals lighthearted tone and poor
word of mouth and bad marketing
ultimately extinguished shazam's Flame
reviews weren't quite as gut punching to
Zachary Levi as they were to Dwayne
Johnson but they weren't good because
I'm too became an afterthought of a
movie that few people felt the need to
see
foreign